[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an indian black comedy
crime thriller film called and had hun
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
a farmer in the outskirts of poona is
being troubled by a hair he chases after
the animal with a gun and takes aim at
it a loud gunshot is heard as the screen
goes blank somewhere in puna lives a
talented blind pianist named akash he
lives alone cooks and cleans after
himself despite his disability akash is
frequently bothered by a kid who thinks
he is not blind the kid goes far and
beyond to try to prove his theory but
hasn't been successful yet one morning
after being troubled by the kid as
always akash goes to a music shop we
find out he plans to move to london in a
month to work in a famous pub the shop's
owner thinks he is a great man for not
letting his impaired vision hold him
back in life then we are introduced to a
former bollywood actor pramad sinha he
lives with his young wife simi on the
posh side of puna despite often being
criticized for the age difference they
are happily married pramod very happily
apart from simi premod's only immediate
family is his daughter from his first
marriage danny she doesn't live with the
couple but visits them once in a while
one afternoon a cache is hit by a
scooter while trying to cross the road
the driver is a girl named sophie who
feels awful even after helping him up
she invites him to lunch as an apology
they talk for a while and upon finding
out akash is a pianist sophie invites
him to perform at her father's
restaurant later that day akash returns
home and takes off his glasses alongside
the foggy lenses this is when it is
revealed that he has been lying about
being blind he rationalizes it as a
method to make his creative senses flow
being blind gives him a vision of music
that he doesn't see otherwise hence he
has been living a lie for the past few
years and making a career out of it the
next day he goes to sophie's restaurant
for the first time and plays the piano
everyone is thoroughly impressed mostly
because they think he is blind
coincidentally premod is also at the
restaurant equally impressed by a cash
his and simi's third wedding anniversary
is in a few days and he wishes to
surprise her with live music akash
promises to come to his apartment to
play for them because the actor wants
their day to be a surprise he lies to
see me that he will be out of town simi
is annoyed but she understands that her
husband is a busy man while returning
home from work sophie has to stay at
akash's home because of the rain he
pretends to not look when she changes
into his clothes in front of him the two
have felt the sparks between them in the
past few days they have been together
soon they begin to make out and spend
the night together in the following
scene akash is outside pramod's
apartment simi opens the door and asks
him to go away because her husband is
not home akash insists that he was
supposed to be here but she doesn't
listen however when an old neighbor sees
them simi feels uncomfortable and lets a
cash in he gets to work and is enjoying
himself but that is until he notices
pramod's dead body on the floor the
pianist is shocked to his core but he
doesn't stop playing simi disregards her
husband's dead body thinking that since
a cash cannot see she has enough time to
hide it a while later he makes his way
to the bathroom and gets a full view of
the dead man while keeping cool he
enters the bathroom only to see that a
man is hiding inside akash pees in front
of him and returns to the piano without
giving away that he is panicking a
flashback shows us that simi and the
stranger were having an affair behind
premod's back on being caught they
panicked and shot him dead while akash
continues playing the killers clean up
the mess and put pramod's dead body in a
suitcase then simi pretends to be
talking to primod trying to make it seem
like he has returned home akash plays
along and leaves after saying goodbye
outside he has to sit down for some time
to take everything in and decide what he
must do next he is approached by a local
lottery ticket seller named saku she
offers to help him by calling him a
rickshaw the rickshaw driver merli
recognizes akash as a regular customer
and brings him to the police station at
his request akash has decided to tell
the police what he saw but seconds
before doing so the head police
inspector manohar arrives he is the same
man who was simi's accomplice in the
murder akash freezes mid-sentence and
pretends to be complaining about his
cat's murder manohar recognizes him
instantly and accompanies him to his
house to see if the dead cat story is
true he also wants to make sure that
akash is actually blind and doesn't know
about pramod's death to do so he throws
a knife at him but akash doesn't flinch
after the inspector leaves akash goes to
the restaurant he works in he knows that
he has to act normal in order to not be
suspected simi also comes to the
restaurant casually telling people that
her husband is out for work then the
next morning pramod's death is
broadcasted on the news as a case of
robbery he was found inside his car by a
bridge with a watch and jewelry missing
manohar takes the case into his own
hands to make sure the truth never comes
out for investigation pramod's daughter
dany simi and akash are all called to
the police station dany seeks
reassurance from simi unaware that she
killed her father meanwhile akash
refrains from telling the truth scared
of ending up like pramod at the funeral
their neighbor mrs desaa who had seen
akash come to the house approaches a
policeman she had been keeping an eye on
the neighbor's apartment on the day of
the death and knows that something about
the story is off simi thinks the old
woman will be a problem if she digs into
the case hence the next time they are
alone she pushes mr saw off the balcony
and kills her to akash's misfortune he
witnesses the incident and has to
pretend to have not seen anything for
the second time he quickly rushes home
and calls sophie planning to tell her
everything what he doesn't know is that
the annoying neighbor kid is taking a
video of him at the same time before
sophie simi comes to his house offering
him sweets from pramod's funeral akash
keeps his guard up and invites her in he
makes coffee for her and then turns
around to see simi wearing a ghostface
mask she wants to startle him and catch
him in a lie but he doesn't give her a
reaction as they chat simi points a gun
at him which makes a cash come clean he
swears that he won't tell anyone about
the murder and that he'll move to london
right away
suddenly he feels dizzy and falls
unconscious it turns out simi had
drugged the sweet that she offered him
when sophie comes to meet him the kid
shows her the video that proves the cash
is not blind she furiously knocks on the
door only to be received by a naked
seamy she pretends to have slept with
akash who is still unconscious a
heartbroken sophie storms off after that
akash only wakes up hours later with a
strange feeling in his eyes he tries
opening them and finds out that he
cannot see anything he has actually been
blinded by simi so even if he tries
telling the truth people won't believe
him what if he tells people he heard the
murder he calls sophie for help but she
blocks his number leaving him with no
options meanwhile the events have caused
a dent in manohar and simi's
relationship he is mad at her for not
killing a cash instead of just blinding
him simi argues she is not a serial
killer sending him to finish the job
when it gets dark the policeman breaks
in and tries to strangle the pianist to
death akash struggles and manages to
escape after hurting him however he has
difficulty navigating through the
neighborhood after really going blind in
the morning he wakes up in a hospital
surrounded by dr swami the rickshaw
driver merli and the lottery ticket
seller saku they found him in the
streets last night and brought him to
the hospital dr swami makes an
appointment with an optometrist at
akash's request his first priority is to
get his eyes checked then to flee the
country however hours pass but he is
never taken to the doctor outside saku
merli and the doctor discuss the amount
of money they are about to earn they are
planning to sell akash's organs in the
black market since he is an easy target
with no family members when they put him
on a hospital bed akash hears them
talking about surgery and panics they
restrain him making it evident that they
are planning to do something bad they
sedate him but before passing out akash
mentions that saku has a lord shiva
tattoo on her arm the three are shocked
because no one ever told him about the
tattoo they think it is a sign from god
and decide to withdraw the plan upon
waking up akash is told he was about to
be killed the group asks him if he is
actually blind a cache of firms and
suggests a better way for them to make
money he hopes that if they get the
money they will spare his life and let
him go then he tells them everything
about manohar simi and how they killed
her husband but he adds that the
murderers have a million bucks that they
can share with the group if blackmailed
their eyes glow with greed and they
decide to help akash after that in the
following scene simi returns home to see
akash playing the piano with danny she
is shocked at the audacity of the guy
and is nervous about him revealing the
truth hence she quickly calls manahar
and asks him to come to a location after
that she offers a cashier ride to get
him to manahar and kill him on their way
akash asks her for 10 lakhs rupees to
keep his mouth shut so he can get a
cornea transplant she refuses to give
him any money but akash already has a
backup plan merli's rickshaw blocks
their car and akash sedates simi when
she is distracted then the group abducts
her hoping to ask manahar for a huge
ransom in exchange for her life next
akash calls manahar's wife rasika and
tells her everything she is asked to
give them a million rupees by tomorrow
if she doesn't want her husband's
reputation to be ruined rasika who has
anger issues loses her mind she
threatens to kill her husband and only
stops when he gets a call the police
found simi's car on a bridge with her
shoes and wallet by the looks of it she
seems to have committed the unthinkable
rasika finally calms down and thinks of
a way to solve the problem meanwhile
simi retaliates and refuses to cooperate
to scare her the doctor draws her blood
and threatens to sell her kidney for
money later that day manahar arrives
with a case full of money as ransom as
they are about to execute the next step
of the plan saku and merli betray a cash
they tie him to a chair and run outside
to go through with their plan on their
own they do not trust akash and want all
the money for themselves ironically
akash and simi are locked in the same
room as the hostages simi laughs at the
absurdity of the situation calling him a
loser akash in turn says that she should
be the most scared because at this point
she is a burden to manahar the best way
for him to get out of this situation
would be to kill her at the same time
the doctor is going through simi's blood
report his face lights up at something
mentioned on the paper and he quickly
goes to meet her in the hideout merly
manages to get the bag of money but
manahar shoots him before he can run
away saku freaks out and traps the
inspector in the elevator stealing the
bag right after then she brings merlie
to the hospital but he is too far gone
to be saved she also finds out the money
she received is fake in the meantime
simi unties the rope around her hands
and attacks akash to kill him but is
stopped by dr swami they get into a
struggle that ends when they knock her
out the doctor puts her inside the trunk
and drives to mumbai with a cash on the
way he explains that simi has a brh
negative blood group which is extremely
rare a wealthy man's daughter is in
desperate need of a liver from someone
like simi if they sell her organ they
will earn more than 50 million bucks
akash can do whatever he wants with half
of it even get a cornea transplant
however he doesn't feel right because he
will have to kill simi for her liver the
scene abruptly cuts to two years later
sophie is on a vacation in europe living
her best life after forgetting
everything that happened with the cash
but the past follows her when she sees a
poster of him outside a pub he is
playing the piano at the pub as he had
envisioned years ago sophie confronts
him and he tells her everything that
happened a flashback shows a swami and
akash driving to mumbai with simi in the
trunk the doctor gets out of the car to
give her another dosage of tranquilizer
but he is attacked and killed in the
process then simi asks akash to get out
of the car and starts driving toward him
she is seconds away from hitting him
when a gunshot is heard it is the same
noise we heard at the beginning of the
film when the farmer was trying to kill
the hare the said hare jumps on the
windshield making simi swerve and crash
she dies in the accident akash takes the
next bus to mumbai and comes to london
with the help of a friend ever since
then he has been working in the pub he
invites sophie to one of his shows but
she has to catch a flight the next
morning they promise to keep in touch
and go their separate ways in the last
scene akash hits a can while walking
down a street leaving us wondering if he
can still see
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on the notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching